jennifer lopez and ben affleck take
their love courtside it feels really
good and it's really nice but i'm so
happy the lovebirds attended the lakers
game in los angeles on tuesday where the
home team beat the boston celtics
117-102 that's a 52-year-old triple
threat rocking an all-denim ensemble
while the 49-year-old oscar winner opted
for an all-black look and the pair
lovingly referred to as benifer were all
smiles laughing and snuggling up it just
turned out to be something really
magical in fact a source tells e.t that
the two were quote very affectionate
with each other throughout the evening
quote during the game jennifer and ben
sat closely to each other and then had
his arm around jennifer for the majority
of the night
this is a thrill i can't stop smiling
the source adds that jen rested her head
on ben's chest they were whispering to
each other smiling and talking during
the game while jen looked at ben
lovingly quote they seemed like they
were in their own little world and so
happy to be there with each other and
comfortable together
and during halftime ben and jen took in
an acrobatic performance which according
to the source they seem to enjoy
i do love that i love it
following the performance the source
says the two spoke to the couple seated
next to them for a bit before lakers
star russell westbrook said hi to ben
and later when a fan yelled out i love
you j-lo e.t sore says she turned around
faced the crowd waved and smiled and
when the game was done quote ben and
jennifer stood up to walk out together
and smiled as they waved goodbye to fans
we're having such a good time the
courtside date night comes just days
after the couple went to the movies with
jen's 13 year old twins max and emmy
whom she shares with mark anthony and
two of ben's three kiddos
twelve-year-old seraphina and
nine-year-old samuel ben shares
seraphina samuel and his
sixteen-year-old daughter violet with
his ex jennifer garner and speaking of
family a source previously told et that
the two are planning on spending
christmas together and want to make it
as special as possible for the kids you
know everything i do is for them you
know once you have kids it's it's a
whole different world it becomes about
them
and what's going to make them happy
what's going to be better for them and
it's this beautiful freeing kind of
loving feeling
where
things get in a way easier because you
know what's important but also harder
because you just don't want to ever fail
them and if that wasn't sweet enough ben
opened up to wsj magazine about his
desire to be a good dad and partner
explaining quote the most important
thing is being a good father the second
most important thing is to be a good man
and a good person and ostensibly you
know a good husband hopefully
cheers to this slam dunk of a couple
[Music]
you